didn't condemned by South Korea as a
serious provocation Thursday's missile
launches by North Korea got this
response from the South Korean president
people could be worried but our
government will thoroughly take care of
people's lives and safety based on a
strong South Korea U.S Alliance and
security cooperation between South Korea
the United States and Japan
since Tuesday's launch of an
intermediate-range ballistic missile
over Japan by North Korea the U.S and
South Koreans have fired their own
missiles in response and the aircraft
carrier the Ronald Reagan which had been
taking part in Naval exercises with
South Korean counterparts has arrived
back in Korean Waters it's due to hold
more drills with Japanese Navy ships
with Tokyo also condemning the latest
missile launches from North Korea
these actions are a threat to the peace
and security of the country the region
and the International Community and its
completely unacceptable the missile
launches came just after the U.N
security Council met to discuss North
Korea's actions with the U.S accusing
permanent members China and Russia of
enabling Pyongyang while making no
specific reference to Tuesday's missile
over Japan North Korea has Justified its
flurry of launches North Korea says it's
only been carrying out countermeasures
against provocations by the U.S and its
allies condemning the return of the
aircraft carrier strike group as a
threat to peace on the Korean Peninsula
with all sides it seems willing to raise
the stakes in this continuing standoff
Rob McBride Al Jazeera Seoul